okay um
i think it's the top of the hour now so
um
hopefully everyone's okay for me just to
start now
uh unfortunately i can't see the matrix
chat um but uh hopefully people can
write their questions and
the shared notes section and uh
yeah um
let's just get started then
and so i'm phillip erin and
i'm the guy working on the gcc front end
for rust and so it's a i'll get into
showing what that is and what it's all
about there's a lot of slides in here to
go through
i just want to point out a little
ferrous crab at the top and right uh the
right hand side where it's holding on to
the
the new logo here i spent probably far
too much time trying to crop off the
the claw and get it layered up correctly
uh
phillip krone has given me the idea from
that to do that one um but i think it's
kind of funny it's just the idea that
you know rust is then grabbing onto gcc
here
and obviously uh well
thanks for open source security and
envelopment as well
so let's see um
next slide
so in this presentation sort of want to
go through a few things and i want to
start talking about like the motivations
of it like the what why and how um you
know why are we working this why you
know what even is it
and
what sort of caveats are there you know
all that sort of stuff and what's our
progress hazard made i want to sort of
give me a little bit of a demo on how it
actually works what to expect when you
actually run this thing you know and
what's the sort of status of it at a
high level i want to talk a little bit
about the community you've been trying
to develop
to talk about you know future work um
and then question and answer sort of
section towards the end
um and so feel free to
stop me even though i can't see the chat
hopefully and you can click the raise
hand or you know do the webcam thing or
put in shareholders i'll try and keep an
eye on these things as we go on
so what is a front end um i stole this
like uh well an old diagram i made years
ago
and it's maybe not the best diagram but
it's just to give you a high level idea
of what i'm actually working on here
so this is sort of a really high level
architecture of a traditional compiler
which so happens to relate quite okay to
gcc so
you've got source code coming in here
and then you've got this notion of a
front end and then it's passing
something over to your middle end to do
optimizations to then pass those over to
the back end to actually then generate
assembly so the piece i'm working on in
here is just the front end itself and
then we're actually you know producing
the generic uh code over to the midland
which then turns into the do the rtl and
all that sort of magic in the back end
which then gives your assembly run your
assembler on it you get your object code
and you run your linker so it's just a
just traditional uh compile um
compile pipeline that you would expect
so there's the piece that i'm going to
be talking about it's just this front
end piece here and the reason i just
want to show this diagram is that you
know it's sort of it's alongside other
front ends and larger system which
you'll also be familiar with
so what is this um so i want to make
a full implementation of rust on top of
the canoe tool chain that's sort of a
high level way to think about it uh you
know we want to make this uh
as as robust as what you would expect
from a normal cnc plus front end from
gcc we wanted to be of the same level
quality we wanted to be upstreamed
obviously so you get a build or if you
get a tarball of tc you will also get
our rust front end as well you know
obviously
in that we are also reusing all of you
know the gnu tool chain here so that
means we're getting to reuse bin utils
ld assembler gb
uh we're also writing this in c plus
plus so that's something maybe to talk
about later on
um
and so
uh that means it's uh much more easily
but strappable um going forward uh
because you know obviously gc is written
in
um
in cnc well cpus was now um and we want
to really want to reuse things like the
the official uh rust neolib core
lip standard
and so on we want to try and reuse those
and as absolute minimal sort of
changes to those as possible
and so that's sort of the the idea of
what this will eventually be
and you'll see it downloaded around
actually show you what it's like to
invoke it and so on
um so personal motivations i think is an
important thing to talk about so you
know i was working on this you know
quite a long time ago um
and so i really do enjoy working on big
projects or something uh really
satisfying about you know sinking your
teeth into something it's got a lot of
scope there um
i think as i mentioned um
i and before the talk started i'm a
really big fan of people like andres
kling and tim morgan you know those guys
on youtube who like you know
broadcasting and showing their hacking
sessions on their projects and i always
enjoyed watching those and even when
their projects are really big it doesn't
matter you learn so much by watching
these guys and you sort of you know it's
the community aspect of that that i
really like
um and then a side note that you know gc
is always going to provide
a contrast to lvm you know um in terms
of you know code size something uh
people talk about liquid whenever
uh there's the website
fronics.com you always see them posting
gc versus lvm so that'll be pretty
interesting down the line especially um
to see how these things compare in terms
of code generation you know it'll be
interesting how well
gc actually handles a modern you know
high level language like this you know
um
although goes there go does rely on a
lot of runtime features um and so it'd
be interesting how tc will be able to
optimize this sort of
something that's a bit more similar to c
plus plus in terms of what you can do
and be interesting the register
allocations you know for all the
different targets it supports and so on
energy efficiency there's all sorts of
different features to compare and
characterize at some point i think
there's already some questions coming in
here
and what mechanism are you using to pull
in the rust libraries as it gets sub
modules and so at the moment we're not
pulling in any uh of
rus sort of code at the moment
um
because we're not there yet to start
compiling libcor lip stand or anything
like that obviously
um
so
i think down the line i think it might
be
uh interesting to try get some modules
but i've had mixed um mixed success with
gifts skip sub modules sometimes they
work for projects sometimes they don't
um i think it'll be i would be nice to
do get some models because but
easier to track things that way but
we'll have to see how how we get on that
point
um
it could very well be that we might end
up choosing to go for
more the approach that gc go did where
you actually you pull in a copy of the
those libraries that you care about or
whatever you want
but um we'll figure that out down the
line
and the other question we have here is
do you plan to use to use and pass the
rust test with yes that's one of the
things we really were passionate about
we want to make sure
we get compatibility with the uh rust
test suite you know that's really
important um
one of the things
that
in some ways i find difficult uh it's
maybe a bit more easy to talk about down
the line but
the rust test does sort of mix a lot of
what it's testing in each test file so
sometimes i i quite like writing test
files that are explicitly testing a
certain thing but that obviously means
downline you also need to write tests
that are you know combining these things
together but a lot of the rust tests it
does combine here i'm using a lot of
these attributes and i'm using all of
this and i'm using all that whereas at
the moment you know i we can't we don't
have lib standard and so on so i can't
use things like transmuting my test
cases yet and so there's we're building
up our own test suite at the same time
as this that's maybe something i'll talk
about at the end about the rationale
behind that
and
so
i'll probably talk a bit more about
testing towards towards the end
and so some of the benefits to talk
about similar to uh on tony's
talk earlier which is fantastic um
you know it provides like an independent
implementation of rust that's you know
separate to the rust tool chain so that
it actually you know breaks the
dependence on rust code here
you know the other part here is that we
do get this tight integration with gcc
you know so we get a lot of the same
benefits as being in tree we don't
necessarily have to you know patch gc we
can just you know talk directly to gcc
as we see fit
um
we that might help you know with rusty
bootstrapping in the future you know
that's been interesting thing you know
we can natively just support gc plug-ins
you know we're already running our test
suite that you know runs lto and so on
because it's just a normal front end it
just acts like a normal front end which
you'll see later
um so there's also like a useful
link in here in the in the notes that
links to a paper but you know you don't
want to do
lto with mixed mixed languages in terms
of like oh i built this thing with clang
and i built this thing with gcc you
can't lose lto and cfi there um so
that's another motivation and benefit
you know you want to be able to provide
the full tc
code generation experience and so you
avoid those problems
you know uh we also want to you know
drive adoption russia so if you're
someone some company that only you know
has a good tool chain you know if you
then
uh
because we're tightly integrated with
the gc hopefully then you just get the
rust front end for free
which might provide more back porting
opportunities and so on
uh for rust in general
uh one of the other things um it's sort
of something as a future goal down the
line this is not something we're looking
at right now but uh we bootstrapped the
front end code from the ccc code
um gc go code sorry um
which means there is actually an
abstraction over gcc in there um which
we could we've been playing around with
to get right for rust you know currently
for when we started it was very go
centric like term for example temporary
variables were prefixed with go temp you
know it's all sorts of silly things like
that and
things were um marked with decal
uninlineable by default and all sorts of
stuff like that and we want to fix this
and maybe change it slash potentially
get rid of it we're not sure but
if we do keep this abstraction in there
one of my goals always was from the
start i'll be really nice to have like
an independent implementation that you
could then pull out and use for like
something completely crazy like i don't
know.net or jvm or something weird um
so that it's just that you just need to
provide a
back-end implementation though in that
we are reusing things like gc's constant
folder so there's hooks in there that we
want to make sure the the target you're
trying to put this compiler into does
give you a constant folder for example
but uh yeah and then obviously we get
the other systems that gcc supports
which is obviously of interest to the
russville nx project
um so how uh as i mentioned the this
project started back in like 2014.
um
the rust was still like 9.7 0.88 around
that time
i just really enjoyed compilers and i've
started finding rust pretty interesting
and i remember the first thing i wrote
in rust was like a lisp interpreter that
was sort of half finished um and i
remember just thinking um you know match
statements were just class i just
thought that was the coolest thing ever
you know you had to look at things like
scala and all those sorts of other jvm
languages to get interesting functional
things like that and but having that in
an actual native language just was that
you just knew that having those features
from the get-go and native language was
going to definitely be popular
and the only thing with that was back in
rus 0.7 update whenever you wanted to
like allocate something on the mem
if you want to put something on the heap
and or if you want to put it on the
stack you had to use these little
modifiers like tilde and an ampersand
and you had to like you know if you want
things to be
boxed and so on you had to use the at
symbol and there was talk about adding a
garbage collector and i remember i had
like a whole bunch of this sort of stuff
sort of working in the compiler at one
point and then i realized hadn't
actually checked what rust was like uh
in the course of two or three weeks and
all of a sudden it was all gone and
that's when the whole like you know
boxing thing started coming in
and uh yeah so it was pretty hard to
keep up with the pace of change because
it did change quite a lot back at the
start
but since like um definitely uh i would
say 2018 for me like uh
that edition really has started to
stabilize the core of the language um
and so i think it since 2018 it did
start to make a lot more sense um brazil
writes some more
smaller projects in that time
uh
just in my spare time which i really
enjoyed
and so
i remember i really did enjoy working
compilers and i thought well let's start
this again let's see what it's like and
so we started the community effort back
in 2019 joined forces with another guy
and and so we merged our like parser and
ast implementation and started moving
forward since then
um but like uh since the recent you know
interest in the roster linux ecosystem
you know i've been uh contacted you know
uh all
um
by brad spengler from food source
security and ebecosm to support this
project and thanks to david ellison from
the gc steering committee for linking
all this up for us and
uh currently i'm actually working on
this full time at the moment so uh thank
you to everyone there for making that
possible for me
um so
currently um i'm planning to try and get
to like a minimal viable product you
know compiler by you know hopefully the
end of uh
next christmas sort of thing that's sort
of where my rough estimate is trying to
get us to something that's compiling
something which basically means probably
something like um rust without a bar
checker kind of like amrasi
but
we'll talk a little bit about the bar
jacker towards the end about that
and so
so far
done a bunch of different stuff i kind
of tried to break down the project into
like sort of high level features you
know it's it's it's pretty difficult to
do that with rust i have to say
um you know so core data structures that
was all but like oh can you actually
um have do you have primitive types can
you compile like an integer and do some
basic math on them uh control flow one
was all about like oh can you actually
you call a function and
take the result of it and all that sort
of stuff and then generics you know
actually having generic structs and
generic functions and generic ample
blocks and all the different associated
things there because you can actually do
treats live until you have generics done
first um so i've done sort of core trait
uh resolution sort of been working
and now we're on the control flow too
which sir is gonna tidy up an awful lot
in the compiler at the minute so
um control flow two is all about oh we
wanna get closures sort of working we
wanna start looking at you know um
uh
pattern matching a little bit we wanna
fix up some of the bits and pieces of
wear constraints and bits and pieces
around that
um which will bring us towards the end
of the year
but then obviously
macros and config expansions they
haven't been started yet imports and
visibility hasn't been started yet
there's all sorts of unstable features
we haven't looked at yet mostly around
um
uh const generics and there's generic
associated types will be coming up and i
think remember reading somewhere that i
could be wrong with this but like the
box keyboard might be getting removed or
something like that might be wrong there
and intrinsics and built-ins and so on
and so they're not really started but
that's maybe not fully true the the
community has actually started an awful
lot of these things so some of this is
all sort of started
um and so that's kind of nice to see
that uh
that maybe there's uh the community
might be able to help me out here a lot
and so yeah let me just give you like a
quick run through what this actually
looks like what do you what will you
actually um get at the end of this
um
so
i'm not sure if you can see my screen
yet i'm not sure what's the best way to
figure this out if you can see my screen
um
viewable
yep we can do it okay
awesome
um
so i've just got a couple examples here
just want to give you an idea of what
this looks like um so let's just do the
classic hello world so as i mentioned we
don't have um
uh
macro expansion and we don't compile a
standard library yet so this is
literally oh here's one safe block to
call printf
um so what does it actually look like
you know rust cg do rust c
minus g whatever um but uh gc rust you
know
you can pilot as if it's like a normal
gc program so i've got the compiler
manage g for debug symbols i'll turn off
um debug because it's kind of a lot of
the examples are kind of cool examples
i'm going to show you um but
uh
there
a lot of the optimizations are actually
working now which is nice um
if i then compile hello and give it an
output of hello
and so then i can run hello so we got
hello world one two three um so i was
satisfied them
there's a slight caveat in the gc
version here is that actually the null
terminator strings not really being used
at the minute because if you don't
specify that it actually works because
i'm using like a gc build string at the
minute which is automatically already
adding the multimeter i we know we have
to fix that but it's just not really a
huge priority right now but i'm trying
to just
use it for now just to show that
it is being respected because there was
a bug and relaxer that actually if you
use an alternating it was just being
stripped out for a while
but anyway
there's hello world working um
that's a kind of just a nice simple
thing to show one of the things it took
a long time to actually get to hello
world and because we only able to get to
killer world because you need to be able
to compile an extern block to say oh
there is an extern function with this
api and it has this um
these uh
these types like it's got a pointer and
it's a radic function
and so that means you need to be able to
call a function you need to be able to
handle extern blocks but the more
complicated the piece is actually this
unsafe part so
we do have
support for unsafe blocks but the bits
here
where rust whenever you
you know assign a value of a string it's
no str
but actually to pass it over to a
some c code you need to be able to do
some casting here so this sort of relies
on having coercion sites at the
assignment operator it also then relies
on casting with the as operator here so
there's sort of really subtle things
going on here to actually be able to let
you compile this in a sensible way
without having to rewrite your type
system again
so that's that's been the reoccurring
theme with actually running a front end
is that so many of the features are
interconnected and so it's very very
important to find the right order in
which you actually build up your
features and so
that's uh it's been actually really
interesting and as i'll show you after
this demo um some of the things i'm
doing around that
um
so the other interesting example might
be something like uh
qualified types is something i've been
working with recently over trade so
um
i know there's a lot of unsafe here but
this is an important test cause it's
actually from the rust nomicon that i've
adapted that you know if you're using
qualified paths it's then bringing you
to the correct you know create function
and so on here
um so we can compile all of that as we
would expect the same thing again
um
relevant optimizations if we want um
file
that's the correct result
just have to take reward for that one
but
but the interesting bit in this uh in
this example is that um
the point of qualified paths was that oh
i've given a nipple block with a
function f but i've also got two traits
with a function f and so you are
actually able to differentiate between
these using the qualified syntax because
if you just use a normal path it will
then default to the implementation which
overrides you know
um but yeah so that's some of the
interesting things you've done around
traits
um another thing we've been really it's
really important to this project is
error handling and so this is just a
really example
uh basic example here but a bad type
error so for example here i've got a is
a boolean here but actually we're going
to pass this boolean to this function
called test so um
you should see an error here basically
um
so yeah expected an ensure got bullion
and so we can see here with the rich
locations you know we can see this is
the the bully in here and we expect it
to get an integer because of this and so
we are working quite hard to try and get
decent error messages uh which is really
important um and for example the next
error message we're gonna show you is um
is an example of why why it's so
important so there's um if i look at
this uh this example um if you have a
generic structure but you have an input
two input blocks here and you've one
that implements it for i size one for
f32 for example
um if you're actually then using a path
here it's impossible for the compiler to
differentiate which function test here
is the correct one because what happens
here is the compiler is going to use the
inference variable to try and figure out
which one but there's not enough
information to differentiate with them
so
for example there you get here is a
multiple candidate error and so you have
multiple applicable items for the scope
the reason that
i do draw
why these are important is that i do use
um error messages to try and figure out
if i'm
if we're tackling the particular
features in the language correctly
because if i can't if the compiler can't
um detect a particular error condition
it probably most likely means there's a
bug in our implementation
and so to be honest most of the time
when i'm going through the rust test
suite i'm looking for our test cases
um and so there is
a lot there to go through
and so it it helps make sure that i feel
sort of confident that we're on the
right track
obviously in this example it's a little
bit noisy as you see this is the actual
error but then we keep propagating the
air um so
there's some tidy up there to do
obviously um but that's something that
happens over time a lot of these are
just sort of catch-alls whenever we uh
when we're going over the intermediate
representations we want to make sure is
this thing actually being called for
this particular expression and so on
um
something a bit more
interesting would be like um
we've got like basic debug support so um
it seems to be working pretty good uh so
i'll show you what looks like debugging
through this code
so we can start it
next you can print what object is and we
get low here it's a
nested struct and it's printing it all
out for us
you know and so we keep going as
you know and they'll show you like nice
little bits and pieces here
um of what things look like uh
i suppose i i should say thanks to the
communities really helped me figure out
how to get um debug support right
because in rust there's there's
conventions about how you generate
the debug support correctly
it turns out if you've got like a tuple
and like the fields with the tuple are
meant to be like prefix with two
underscores and things like that to get
the proper debug support so there's sort
of little caveats in there to like
figure out the right way to get this
stuff and done basically
um the other thing it's worth showing if
hopefully this doesn't
go crazy here um i try to be uh really
open about like how i'm tackling this
project so one of the things i did was
make this sort of spreadsheet and i sort
of went through the rust like book to
try and like
take out all these like high level
features
and try and say try and figure out the
best way like where are we in this
um
and sort of track it this way
it was difficult to set up the start but
i think it's been worthwhile
um to try and figure out where we are
but the other thing is i keep this like
uh reporting repository open on github
so
we
keep um a weekly report on a monthly
report so it keeps track of everything
that we're doing and i like to go into
detail about
what the contributors are doing i really
do like to pick up like what work each
every person is doing and i like to show
examples and talk about the examples
uh about how they work and so on so um
i've got multiple tabs that open so a
report might look like this so we've got
um some sort of audi ref working so we
finally will do methods with you know
without having to have the exact type
you know the compiler will inject the
reference and so on
and there's also we fixed up some of the
debug support so we'll give links to
like compiler explorer whenever the rust
relax project give this example for us
for
uh for the different compilers there was
a bug here that we weren't actually
getting this um optimized correctly so
now we are getting it optimized so it
will detect this
you know and i like to be able to
describe you know um
show where are we with the issues how
many issues have been created how many
test cases have we added and how many
bugs have been found how many bugs fixed
what sort of percentage are we going
through any risks and so on
and so that's kind of a rough overview
of
um
how the project looks like at the minute
so we'll stop sharing
um
the
uh
another question i get off that is this
uh compiler pipeline the work this um
this uh
diagram is a little bit out of date uh
there's some extra steps in here
obviously but the overall idea is like
oh there's a lexer it's a partial we get
an ast and
we have a macro expansion path but it
doesn't really do anything there's um
there's hooks in there though that we
actually at there's see macro expansion
config expansion are two separate things
but it's represented as one thing here
and so not quite right we've got aim
resolution we've got hr lowering we've
got type resolution and then we've got
um our generic backend which is a
terrible name but that's us you know
generating the gcc code let me give it
to gcc so we aren't doing mar because i
think mar looks a lot like um
gcc's generic in a lot of ways um
but
yeah it's kind of rough overview of what
it sort of looks like
and we'll talk a little bit about the
community and so one of our contributors
mark uh he sent us this lovely picture
he's got his custom keyboard project
here it's got a little ferrous and
for all the contributors i've actually
sent out a little mug to say thank you
saying compilers are hard and they most
definitely are hard but they're pretty
satisfying and it's also holding onto
the wii a canoe logo
um
and so the goal here is you want to make
working on compilers fun um obviously
i'd mentioned earlier we've done status
reporting and i want to shout out to all
the contributors every time i do that
and be as open and transparent and
one of the things we do have is this
monthly community call it's in the first
friday of the month it's kind of a good
time for me
because that's 10 a.m for me at the
moment um but i think it might be
looking at either doing a second call or
moving the call to maybe if there's
people from different time zones looking
to join
and but most of our contributors are
within europe at the moment so
it's worked out okay now for so so far
and so we do that and anyone's anyone's
um anyone's welcome to join this uh we
give out the details in our status
reports um like how to join it there's
just a jitsi link um and so you don't
need to necessarily join up to our zulub
server or join our irc or mailing list
or anything you can just click on the
jitsi link you can turn your camera off
and just listen or some people like to
participate and ask us questions and so
on
we're also part of google summer code
2021 and we had two projects that went
pretty well and um uh
our first project was the cargo gcrs
project by arthur so he was actually
able to then give us a
uh i think it's using like the rusty
rapper interface and with cargo to
actually let us you know map what the
expected arguments are from what what
cargo thinks the correct arguments are
over the gcc arguments that's so the
goal here is that we want to be able to
provide
um the correct sort of interface that uh
that people would expect because people
are most likely going to be running this
project from uh from a cargo perspective
so it looks like a cargo sub command so
it'll look like cargo gcrs blah and you
know and so we get uh all that support
uh the other project was um uh student
from china and he was also able to give
us a dead code pass so like as i
mentioned earlier we do put a lot of
effort into what our error handling
looks like but that also means you know
one of the other great things about the
rust compiler is that it's got really
good warnings
and while it was important one of those
would be the dead code pass to me um
and so there's
he was able to provide us with
basically following very similar
algorithm to the russia one um which was
satisfying
so we'll find all the entry points and
then go through all of those to find
where dead cool will be also even able
to find you know are there fields being
used or not instructs
so the other thing is like you know
anyone's welcome to get involved in this
project um it is a gcc project um
but so i want to give a wee bit of a
shout out to some people there was joel
who served with parser in ast you know
and then recently you know mark wheeler
was able to add support for unions you
know uh you know mark police was able to
add module support arthur gives support
for module expansions he's working on
uh the v0 mangling and so on there's
also thomas you know it keeps us up to
date with gcc and built our test suite
with mark and you know i i really thank
all those contributors so much there's
there's been a lot more contributors
than that i've given out over 20 mugs
[Music]
at this point and
uh i just think it's important to say
that you know this project there's a lot
of scope for people to you know make
their mark on the compiler like to
actually own something or get experience
if they wish
um
and uh i want to make it as fun and as
enjoyable as possible
um so we keep a list of like you know
good first pr's and so on um and you
know so we do offer some sort of
mentorship there and we try to give good
guides so we like sort of listen like
you know on tasks and so on that
that task would break down into
and we get a lot of really good support
from uh from phil crones and bjorn here
like they uh help us figure out some of
the nuances with um rust in general and
sometimes it's hard to figure out all
these bits and pieces of rust and that
really not all contributions have to be
coded especially
um
when you're trying to figure it like
oh russ is actually doing a move here or
you know that how does this qualif like
recently trying to figure a qualified
pass was kind of difficult
um
you know so it is uh
really nice that people do join and
offer us help that way
also it's really we are in compiler
explorers as shown and so feel free to
you give us test cases bug reports that
there's going to be plenty of bug
reports to to raise obviously we're in
an early phase but i think finding the
bugs early is useful
um
and so uh future work so one of the
things we haven't on the roadmap at all
this at all is uh borrow checker uh but
my i personally think the best scenario
would be for us to start looking and
working with the pelonius project and
because that would give us maximum
compatibility with the borrow checker
and it is such a core piece of the rust
ecosystem as getting that right so i
think in definitely in the short to
medium term we have to be looking at
working with the pelonius project um
i don't know if there's much appetite to
rewrite a borrower checker and c plus
plus
um
but yeah that's uh it's definitely often
the distance for me right now to even
think about and it doesn't that's the
bar checker doesn't really drive
anything to do a code generation so far
as i found
um you know um
the drop trait you know it's kind of if
you can figure that out without
requiring a borrow checker
one of things we haven't done is
incremental compilation as well you know
like the the rust tool chain it works by
like um
everything in the crate is a single
compilation unit so whenever you have a
mod keyword that has to load that file
so that means you know your actual
compilation unit is actually encompassed
of many files
uh as i mentioned at the start talk we
were interested in you know potentially
with this abstraction trying it out with
other compiler infrastructures that's
definitely way down the line we know
there's no point even trying that until
we get it working with gcc first um but
it's something i find interesting at the
start when working on this project
um
and the other thing is we do really
think it's really important to drive
compatibility so we are seeking to
potentially you know create like a
testing project there uh we do want to
try and reuse the rusty test suite uh
one of the issues
potential issues there is that you know
the
the gc code is a gpl project but the uh
rus uh test feed is like you know mit or
something i can't then just copy the
test suite into gcc code and pretend
it's ours you know so
it'd be nice to have like a separate
project that will actually have some
sort of driver to then invoke those test
cases dependent on the compiler you want
because at the minute um our test suite
is using deja gnu whereas the rusty test
suite is a different thing i don't know
what it uses under food but it would be
nice if we could actually just run the
test suite as we would expect um down
the line um because at the minute we're
sort of cherry picking test cases and
actually test our code against and then
the other thing would be i'll be
interested in that down the line to
backboard the front end because we have
built this
front end based off some
gc co code like which was built like
a gc5 or something like that you know
there's a lot of scope to backport this
so if we keep the abstraction in a
certain way
in theory it shouldn't be that painful
and but
that's one of those things it's like oh
it's a one-line change but really it
turns into months of work um but yeah
oh there's some questions i think coming
in
um
to what extent could you reuse rust
libraries within the front end for
instance you assume the traits are one
of the largest blocking gaps could you
pull in chalk library which implements
the rustrate system increasing parts of
the
compiler being modulized to reuse rust
so that that's definitely been posed
quite a few times to us at the start um
one of the issues i have with that is
that i personally think it's a better
solution for the long term if we can
break the dependence on the rust tool
chain i think having a separate bar a
separate implementation really helps
with that and potentially maybe down the
line after the the gene has been broken
then you could start doing something
like that
um
i i just not sure what
only the only benefit it brings to me is
oh it sort of might reduce some work but
at the same time
it's not really helping with
bootstrapping or getting it onto
different platforms because you're then
still limited to the platforms rusty
supports
um
i kind of think
it's better to break the dependence
if you say how easy it is to add support
for architectures yeah so one of the
things because we
are reusing a lot of
gcc stuff here we are already working on
many different target platforms
um and so it we do actually thanks to
mark's build farm we are actually uh
testing that regularly and which is nice
to see and there's um
there's been a debian developer uh john
paul adrian globotz he's been really
interested in mips and so on um so
that's been pretty cool we
the actual
act of you know testing the compiler on
these different platforms has
uh actually
rattled out some interesting bugs as
well so for instance like float 64s just
didn't really seem to work at all uh
until we got some patches through there
um
and but yeah so it's been pretty useful
and to test it on these different
platforms
um
a lot of what the language in rust is
a lot of what looks like the language in
rust is part of the standard library
some
what like java how good rust can be at a
gc front end without tight integration
without a standard library how does it
work with tight cargo integration
i'm not quite sure i understand what the
question is here
um i'm sorry i'm trying to figure out
what the question is of that one
for an end user we'll see it's not there
do you mean like oh
cargo support to
yes
maybe um some of those who are typing
questions can just basically ask them
verbally and
turn the camera on
as well if they're having troubles
and user let's see he's not there he's
reduced cargo and stuff so
it's a bit odd without all the stuff
so
i think
um
trying to answer that question uh
do you mean like we don't have the
standard library or something well the
goal here is that we will be reusing the
standard library and you will be uh gc
russ built standard library lib core
level up and so on that would be the
goal here and we want to minimize the
incompatibilities that could arise out
of that
um
as yes so i don't really think uh and
obviously we have the thanks to arthur's
google summer code we have the cargo
support now at the minute you know we've
been trying to address these questions
early um to try and key in as
much
trying to get ahead of those potential
problems
i'm not sure if that answers your
question or not though
um
but a
special thanks to to brad spengler and
jerry bennett and david ellison because
you know they've been really helping me
navigate this project in general um
you know
brad and jeremy are sponsoring my work
here and i get a lot of mentorship from
david to figure out how to actually go
about this project you know being a
maintainer like this is uh is new to me
and i i really do enjoy working on this
project and i'm hoping i'm making it
enjoyable for the community so far
um so yeah questions here's all the
relevant links by the way for like if
you want to figure out where everything
is and we have a mailing list as well
we're on irc and zooloop and everything
oh hi miguel
hey phillip thank you thank you for the
talk uh thank you well i was going to
make you the same questions i made to
anthony in the previous talk which is uh
just in case you have some uh some input
uh so basically you know in the kernel
we use binding to generate the binders
to parse the c code and generate the
equivalent to the c headers for us yeah
but that uses lift clan
which poses a problem because of course
with gcc it could be the case for
example in particular if you are using a
plugin you see the randomizers for
example
the layout fast track for example then
the api wouldn't be compatible so do you
think or do you are you planning to
perhaps work on that perhaps it's a
priority project or somebody else to add
support for writing
one hour ago it's not possible easily
with gcc to
get into the middle of the
scene
i have some experience with that
actually because um i did google summer
code like in 2010 and 2011 and so on
well one of the years i did it with um
the python foundation so i actually
worked on syphon at one point
and so the project there was actually
trying to write a python plugin to then
generate all what what siphon calls pxd
declarations a similar similar idea
and one of the things there is it worked
actually pretty good the one of the
problems was actually getting the
information from um
uh
my preprocessor macros you couldn't
access those because they're all sort of
encapsulated then into the ir
and but the overall problem that really
stalled the project from being useful
was that if you use this you could pilot
plug-in and run it but at different
subsequent gc versions the behavior was
completely different
um and so that made it kind of difficult
um but as far as i know a lot of that
has stabilized the right whenever i was
doing that project gc plug-ins were kind
of just new and the whole the gc was
changing quite a lot so that was like
gc45 or something like that i was
working and then we were quite far away
from that now and i think it would be
definitely worth investigating like a
plug-in approach like that to get
information um
i think uh
well like it's it's an interesting thing
you say there because at the minute one
of the things our front end doesn't
support this one this doesn't sound
related but it is supports related
or it doesn't support like uh parsing
like utf-8 stuff which russ does um and
so at the moment in gc there's like code
in the c front end there's code in the
go front end to do this but they're all
separate implementations
um you know and it would be nice to
start trying to unify some of this work
to actually be able to call each other's
code instead of having to re-implement
any everything like another similar
problem that i had was right logging in
this compiler i've currently been using
a lot of rust debug just printf stuff
but you know dave malcolm has this
awesome logger there and i've got a
patch to then extract this out so i
think some of the i think
some of the problem there is that we
could maybe work better you know making
reusable parts of gcc um uh which is
what i would be interested in doing and
so and to answer your question i think
it'd be worth trying again um
given where we are now but uh yeah i
think uh one of the things that's
interesting here is that because i'm
tightly integrated with the front end uh
tightly integrated with gcc we're
actually able to call all bunch of stuff
so like as far as i remember there's a
bunch of stuff for like security and v
tables and all sorts of crazy stuff like
this that i could potentially reuse from
the g c plus plus front end and so
that's what i'd be interested in seeing
is um can we extract things out to make
this easier for more front ends in
general
i think i want to round about way to
answer your question there but
if i understand no i i mentioned this
and i also has company because basically
for any project not just but any project
that is written in c and they want to
when they want to adopt trust they will
run into this uh like i want to
generally automatically generate the
binders because i don't want to write
them manually of course and then there
is this possibility of
officer slicing like as a piece of a
tootsie so to speak
yeah i see it as a piece of ecc i i
could even see it as a piece of let's
say
yeah
yeah but of course i mean many user
space projects it works even with lip
plan it would be compatible so it would
not be any problem so it's only special
projects i guess but yeah
yeah
i think that's one of the benefits of
rust though it has really good support
for stuff like that like any other
project like site for example you have
to go manually create all these things
and it it makes it so ugly if something
dare changes and like swiggle get you so
far but swag gossel has its own issues
you know but i also do quite like swag
at the same time
of course we actually um i forgot to
mention there's actually a project has
it called blake8 or something like that
on github it's like a nice minimal rust
program so we're hoping to be able to
compile up by christmas um it basically
doesn't really use any real like um
standard library stuff there's a couple
in there but we can extract it out i
think so i'll be interested to see how
many bugs we find because whenever you
posted that rust for linux
compiler explorer example there was like
five or six actual bugs in there in our
compiler
there was what people only noticed was
that it was missing and optimization but
what i saw there was like six bugs
they're all fixed now
but that's i think i i was initially
pretty nervous about being in compiler
explorer but it's been really worthwhile
because it's better tackling these
problems
sorry
but i think it was pretty nice it's very
nice to have it as much possible
no i think it was fun
i mean 10 people using an anger and
finding the real bugs instead of us
finding it right down at the last minute
thank you no problem
um
clarification rust libraries
i understand that you want to be able to
bootstrap via gc i'm asking once you
have some minimal level of rust support
could you then introduce rust code into
the front end which would then allow you
to reuse rust code yeah that's
definitely something
i've considered um
i think we're still quite far away from
doing something like that but that's
definitely i would prefer that approach
than doing it from the get-go
uh yes so uh
i just want to give a shout out you know
there's um
open source security inc uh they've been
sponsoring project as well as ember cosm
and so you can find their urls
on google
so
and also
gc steering committee as well
if i go back a slide you can get their
links
if other companies are interested um
[Music]
i'm not sure if i can talk about all
that yet i
think this has been um
we want to try and drive to create a
project that other companies are
interested in joining
um i think
um
yeah so we want to make it sure it's uh
something that solves something for the
community and and we want to make sure
it's welcome for other people to join in
and work with us as well there's
something raised hands how do i um do i
have to click on that or
yeah
if you click on that that should do it i
can't see it when you're presenter sorry
i clicked on something i don't know if
that was the right thing to do
it was me oh yes
all it was was to say that you know brad
and i
are not exclusive about sponsoring this
project it's a great project
but there are more people coming down
the track and welcome an opportunity to
be supported on that and we'd encourage
other sponsors coming forward to assist
with that so you can reach out to any of
the three names on there if you're if
you think you might like to
sponsor
uh in any way
and thanks for uh you guys sponsoring my
work it's been it's been a really great
year for me you know i do really like
rust and i really like gcc i've always
wanted to work on it full-time
in my previous experience i've done
mostly llvm work but uh yeah
i've always have a soft spot for working
on gcc
um
i think i've
done all the questions um
unless i've missed any
yeah i think you've done them all as
well so
on that note i guess probably
um you know keep an eye on the
chat when you're actually able to have
access to it
and um
thank you very much for a really good
time much appreciation thank you
okay have a good day everyone